Okay. So then if we can introduce this,
how would you convince the many
people listening to stay listening?
Cause it's a great story. It doesn't
matter that it's figure skating.
It's like a really good story. It's
a good story that like pops off of.
It's like, Hey, I'm Jad, I bring Ron,
I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and La.
I've never been a huge
fan of figure skating.
But like this story I think asks
a really interesting question.
The question would be,
what if you with all your heart
wanted to be the best at something,
but the persons who judge, what's the
best at this? Something you want to do,
don't share the best with
your sense of business.
So you do your best and their best and
your best are different and now you can't
best it out. What do you do? What do
you do? Story comes from our producer,
Latif Nasser and also producer
Tracy Hunt. Okay. Okay. Okay.
All right. Okay, so let's
start then. So okay,
so we're starting in 1998 we're at
the Olympics in Nagano in Japan,
Japan. And so we've seen
warming up on the ice.
You have this woman, this figure Skater
Serea Bonnelly how do you spell? Yeah.
S. U. R. Y. A. She's French,
24 years old. She's flat
less than five times European
champion, but all sorts of problems,
particularly injury problems.
She's got an Achilles tendon that's
been stitched together, hold a muscle.
He's on painkillers and [inaudible]
he did for France in 1994
and just missed the podium.
Never metal with the
Olympics before. This is her,
probably her last go, um,
in, in front of the world.
But France,
there is Suria bodily and it was during
this performance that's [inaudible]
fondly did something that had
never been done by anyone.
Anyone ever. And you
could either see it as a,
as a kind of middle finger to the
establishment, like this huge SFU
or
just this beautiful moment
of self affirmation.
[inaudible]
what'd she do? Uh, we'll get there. Hello.
Hello. How are you doing? Pretty good.
Thanks. I laughed out loud when I,
when I heard you say that you would
call me on your Zamboni break.
I know it was like this.
The only time. Okay.
So to really understand just the context
of all this and the stakes of that,
that moment, we got to go all
the way back. So. So how did you,
how did you first get into skating? Well,
I did start skating
because of my mom actually.
So Suria was actually adopted as a baby
by this white couple in the south of
France. She grew up in Nice.
My mom was a sport coach
and she was able to be a,
like a volunteer for a
gymnastic club and skating club.
So even though I was
small, tiny, tiny, um,
she just put me on the eyes
and say, hey, just hang around
and chill on the ice and you know,
and I spend lots of hours there just
waiting for my mom and one day I go find
out that's a hat, you know,
some skidding boots who fit
me. And she started skating.
Yeah. Fortunately I was good at it.
Pretty soon she had a
coach from the local ring,
I guess a coach can have called and
having a meeting with your parents. Say,
Hey, you know, it'd be nice if you
could come like two times a week,
probably may now. We'll be nice. We'll
do maybe four times a week. Well,
how about every day it was
like, okay, here we go.
And so by the age of 10 she decides she
wants to spend her life figure skating.
It was my dream to, you know,
to do it. And I know I can.
So she would go to these ice
shows like holiday or nice.
So when this is a show, I love
being, I love showtime and just,
you know, those fantastical students,
she would see all these famous skaters
dotting my i's guru on those skaters.
They would just be flying through
the air. It was like amazing.
And she would go to practice and she
would practice all of the things she saw,
all the,
the double axles and the triple pill loops
and speed jumps and that sal cows and
the double sal cows and the, you know,
quadruple double the triple action.
Do you have any idea what you're
saying right now? No, no, no.
These are all just words to me.
It was very fast that every week,
every month you can see a difference.
And speaking of difference, you know,
if we fast forward a little bit
and here she is on the world
stage, sorry, urban la in 1989
when she appears at the world champion,
the thing that becomes
really apparent is that
she is different. Yeah.
Because I was black so I was like
people like what? Oh, French black.
So I'm black and I definitely
remember when she was a baptist skate,
my mom would be like, the
black girl was skating.
So we all had to like pay
attention. And so people saw to whom
you can of curious, this girl is
very different than Oh, it was, um,
it was arrested. That's done at Howard.
He new writer for espn.com Obama Lee is
a striking and exotic figure on the ice.
She, you just arrested your
eyes when she skated. The,
the contrast of her skin
on the ice was beautiful.
[inaudible]
and then there were these fanciful stories
that sprung up about where she came
from.
We are now taking you about as far away
from the skating world as possible.
Pretty much as soon as she hit the scene
and you started hearing these rumors
that she had been adopted from a coconut
strewn beach in reunion island off the
coast of Madagascar
and unlikely place to find it.
World-Class figures, candor. Right. And
that she had, um, that she,
what was it though to us here,
here that she never cut her hair,
cut her hair since her birth,
that she existed on a diet of bird seed
and you know, all these things. Yeah.
Id like 60 some kind of black
forest princess or exactly. Exactly.
Yes. Suria says, you know,
at that age she really didn't know
too much about what was going on.
I know as a kid I was like, whatever
my coach deal, it's, you know,
he's the one who speak English.
See, you're barely speak English.
She was barely 16. She wants to
live a young baby. I, you know,
I did talk to the Guy who
was coaching her at the time,
this guy named DDA Guy Gay and,
and he told me he planted these stories.
We use the press very well. Wait, what?
He said that he made up the beach thing.
He made up the hair thing because
he was trying to, she was a star.
And what are you willing to hear
stories, right? So we made some stars,
some good ones. Do you know what I mean?
I'm just saying that we making up
stories because you want to hear them.
That is just creeped out. Yeah, you're
absolutely right. It's Shitty as hell.
I can kind of see where he
was going because what he
was trying to do with that,
he was trying to present her to the
world as this like radically new kind of
skater because female
skating at that moment
where Nice, cute girls,
especially for ladies,
they like to keep the girls
parading hours for Catarina.
So it's famous skater like Katharina
with the ravishing Karina or Sonya Haney
is, we're like totally like
woman, you know, pretty graceful.
Who makes those men's, you know crazy.
When you were watching it's, you know,
they were also,
why would I say they?
They had a certain
conception of females. Katie,
we didn't have the same one and it
wasn't just that she looked different.
She also skied it different. Lee,
it was a totally different
approach. Suria was always very like
[inaudible] explosive
ladies and gentlemen. Elvis
Stojko is in the building,
retired world figure skating champion
and met three at junior's 1990 for me it
was sort of a new, a new face on
same part is the the like the fresh
stick of Yom tiny 15 year old French girl
who's captured everyone's
imagination here.
Say a Tonya Harding style skating.
She was just so exciting and there
was just no boundaries for her.
This is Tonya Harding and she and surreal,
the strength and the power.
She'd step on the ice and yeah,
people were crazy too. Yeah.
She strike a pose and then just take off.
Suria would go from one end to the other
speed across the ice line across the
room with powerful stroking, her opening
at triple lights in a triple tall.
She comes early into these jobs,
soaring through the
air with powerful spin,
NTT jump back jump.
That really was a cool combination
after combination other dreadful,
I prefer to hit a triple, triple jump.
Then just to do a pretty spray goal
and she would attack everything.
That's a very first step.
Secrets she had the stepping,
the gliding through running. Okay.
She had an all talent and the crowd here.
I appreciate it
is such jumping ability and there's
no end to what she might achieve.
Side of competitions. You could
do these ice shows and exhibitions
and that's when you would see
like what she can really do.
Just do all kinds of other jumps that
weren't even allowed in competence,
you know, didn't backflips
she would do that. Yes.
That slips very first time that I ever
saw her do a back flip. I mean I just,
my mouth just dropped open. That's
tiny Harding again. I was like,
how did you do that? Because
it's really dangerous.
Elvis Stojko told us that one time
he tried it and it did not go well.
I came down right on my face and I split
my eye open and almost broke my neck
and I was just like, you know what?
I don't think this is going
to be a good thing. You know,
this little teenage girl
cerea bodily, no problem.
Just doing it like it was
nothing. Absolutely fearless.
And the crowd loved it.
People like
Dunlop is south making noise and
tubs or fits into the ground.
I can feel the lugs, a whole
grueling building. I'm like,
I swear it looks like an earthquake, but
here's what happened.
And this is where things kind of get
confusing as Syria blows up and all these
people who never liked figure skating
fall in love with her over and over,
the judges don't artistic impression.
And you just see disparity
from the judges and the crowd.
You're not like the mark
subset. No doubt. Even when
she doesn't get high scores,
no tears begin to flow happen
all the time. I escaped. Good.
But somehow I, it's not for me.
[inaudible]
so the judging system and figure skating
goes from zero to six and on Syria's
artistic marks,
she would get scores like five
zero five zero five ones. Yeah,
you get your low fives, which
like sounds like it's a good mark,
but that's not a good,
there he is. What did
you think of those Meyer?
Very, very disappointed.
[inaudible] never mind.
What'd you say there? She said,
nevermind. That's life. I'm used to it.
I fought it. Sue Sports sports
mean challenge every day.
I try to do the best that I could
do. You do your best is fine,
but clearly there were some
times where I got hurt.
There was this one time we
found on youtube where she,
she boozed the judges after she
gets her score crowd is bullying.
Well we said why was she getting bad
marks to begin with? What was the,
what was the problem? Well, that's the
question and it's kind of complicated.
I think there's several things.
I'm Janet Howard, that ESPN writer.
She says, the first thing you got to know,
and just to take a quick little dive into
the Weirdo world figure skating bucks
dive, is that there's this
fundamental tension in the sport of figure
skating between artistry on one side
in athleticism on the other and
powerfulness [inaudible] readiness.
They want these people to
look like little ballerinas,
but leap into these jumps like
predators. And at the time,
skating was sort of locked in this loud
and fractious debate about what do we
want to be. And Suria was sort of
the epitome of almost the end point.
What could happen if somebody
with unrivaled athleticism
and no aversion to risk
was willing to go after it.
And I think there were a lot of
people in skating that didn't want it.
I went through it. I know all about it
now. Tonya Harding, she said
that she had this issue.
I didn't want to skate like what they
wanted skating to look like Elvis Stojko
to butt. In Maria's case,
there's a lot of work to be done on the
choreography yet there's a lot of work
to be done on the grace. Oh those
words used to criticize her skating.
There's a lot through to who fixed.
I'd like to see your stop jumping
for six months in women's escape.
We're just a little bit more loaded.
They would say things like, oh,
we're all tied up in a different,
it's a lot of raw talent but it's not a,
it's not fully kind of
hasn't been refined and,
and it's for us like non skaters.
Like that's been one of the challenges
of this story I guess is like trying to
see like is that a legit criticism?
Alright. Is this just a way
of saying that sees black?
They chose racism. I have the courage
to say it because she was black.
So this is Marie Ren Laguna and she is
a former French figure skating official.
And She was part of a team whose job
it was to decide which girls to send to
the, uh, world junior championship.
And then we have to choose to only two
girls. And we had three possibilities.
She said that she backed serea and
the majority of the people didn't,
didn't want them. Black Skaters. Um,
were they saying it out loud?
Look, we don't want somebody,
we don't want her because she's black.
It was very [inaudible]. In fact,
according to her, what
they would say, she,
they would say the kind of things like
she was too muscular or she wasn't
elegant enough. Oh yes. I have
to say that's word. Elegance.
Many times I have heard that
word and she's got to elegant.
Marie [inaudible] is an outsider in the
figure skating world these days because
of an unrelated scandal.
And so we weren't totally sure
what to think about that. But wait,
how did Ceria feel about
all this? Well, I asked her,
did you feel like any of the difficulty
was because you're black? No,
I feel like any of it was about
race. No, no, no, no, no, no.
But then moments later she said,
well, you know, when you block, you know,
everybody knows that you have to do
better than anybody else who's white.
Well, I think the idea that
she was held back in Martin,
her marks for any other reason other
than the quality of your skating,
I think is incorrect.
That Sandra, I'm been
involved in the skating world my whole
life as a competitor, as an Olympian,
a commentator,
and actually as a commentator I'd like
to see him stop jumping for six months
and living to skate. She was
kind of hard on Syria. Yes.
And when we asked her why,
this is what she said,
everything about skating
is built on circles.
The radius could be huge,
but it's still a circle.
Everything is about edges and leaning
into those edges and leaning into the
turns and and carving
massive circles on the ice.
And that is our sport,
which leads to Syria.
I mean if you watch your jumps there,
they were on straight lines and
if a jump is on a straight line,
then it can't land with flow because the
idea is to land your jump with as much
speed and flow as you had going into it.
And that's something that she couldn't
do because she was jumping on straight
lines.
And then the other thing about skating
that you don't necessarily get on camera
is the sound of the edge,
the sound of, of a beautiful
skater going from edge to edge,
from lean to lean. What
does that sound bad? It's,
it's a beautiful sound. It's a
sound that we all love. It's a,
it's a, it's a gentle carving. Um, image.
Clean sound in my head is
like, like a hockey stock.
But that's probably not the, no, no,
no, no, because there's no there.
I can tell you there are
no scratches. It's a glide.
It's just a, it's a ham. I, Gosh,
I wish I had a good word to describe it.
And there are different sounds. I mean,
like there's the sound of Brian Boitano,
his back crossovers that, you know,
used to like excite me when
I was in the rink with them.
But then there's also sort of
the gentle, almost soundless,
um, quality of say a UK Asato
or a Katia Gordeeva, um,
where they're like a whisper across
the ice. And yet they're, you know,
flipping from one edge to another
edge. Um, and, and forward to backward.
And it's almost,
it's just that this glide, um,
I haven't got a good word for it.
Yam. So when, when Suria was skating,
would she have that
sound? No, she would be
scratchy
male, we should say.
That wasn't the sound of Ceria
skating or any of those other people.
We just like miked up a whole bunch
of like pretty good finger skaters.
Were they professional
skaters? Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
These are legit scares figure skaters.
And we sent the clip to
Sandra and she was like, yes.
So she gave you the thumbs up that
we get it right? Yep. Let's see.
I don't necessarily hear whatever
it is she is hearing and think. Yes.
I mean they sound different but
not even that different really.
So that's exactly the problem.
Uh, ice skating is largely
about aesthetics. So as
far as sports go, it's,
it's like kind of in its own category.
Like if you're talking about Serena
Williams who's facing a lot of these same
kinds of criticisms, it doesn't matter.
There's a line on a court and it's either
inside or outside, there are rules,
whereas there aren't these rules.
When it comes to beauty, it's,
it's super slushy
and that makes someone like
Sareah much more vulnerable.
So. So what ended up happening?
Well after a couple of years of getting
these kinds of marks, does she eat,
does some soul searching?
I mean I was a bit more mature in 1992
at the age of 18 I had new curl grad
changed my whole skating walls, you know,
I change cultures and she
decides to take the note.
She actually travels to California and
works with Frank Carroll who's like this
legendary American coach. And what
she's doing is that she's trying to,
you know, be more graceful,
more beautiful, more elegantly,
more circley. Yeah.
And after that you kind
of see a difference.
You can watch the youtube
videos from that period and it,
it's like she's a different skater,
Huh? Yeah. Does it work yet?
In 1993 in the world championships,
she comes in second and then by the time
1994 rolls around, she is a favorite.
She is, she is probably gonna win.
And what happens? Things
take a really strange turn.
We'll be back right after
the same buddy break.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hi there. This is Kirsten
recording from Orlando, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Radiolab. Uh,
let's get back to our story about Suria
bodily or Bernali as it said in French
from producers, Tracy Hunt and
lot of Nasser. I, I was, I was,
I'm really curious what,
what happened at that,
at that metal ceremony in 1994, um, oh,
as a Walsh in between the world champion,
not the Isaacs. Yeah, no, no, no, no,
no. Well, we had this water
and been shipped in Japan,
seven Olympic titles,
17 world championship.
Just to set this up,
the world championships or the second
most important event in figure skating
after the Olympics and
at the Olympics. Richard,
just a month before the top three ladies,
16 year old Oksana Baiul Oxana
by Yoga Gold Nancy Kerrigan.
It's just fancy care. Again, got silver.
10 Lou got the bronze and
fourth plays with Ceria.
Now those top three ladies, Oxana,
Nancy Lou out of the picture,
out of the picture for various reasons
and juries and some turn pro and stuff,
but whatever the point is at these
rural championships, the the,
the highway had been cleared for
Maria. She was going to take it.
It was hers.
Take us through her winning
season. Will it be gold? So jumping
forward to the final day of the
championship, Suria is in second place.
She takes the 80 years old from
Nice in the south of France,
starts their program.
[inaudible] immediately starts with
this double axle that's very incredible.
After that is just triple,
triple, triple, triple, triple.
And that man was still [inaudible].
It was just one of the best skates
of her life. I knew I did my best,
I did everything.
It was not perfect because
nobody's perfect but pretty
good come to competition
overall. Eventually after
about four and a half
minutes,
she finishes her skate or you're going
to lay the ball days for seasons loads
and loads of technical difficulty.
The question is how will I see
her artistic effort goes over,
ah, off to the side, to a bench with
her coach, um, to await her result.
[inaudible]
technically called narrow and
some five nines at plays or
those are as high as any we've seen.
When she gets her marks, she
jumps into first place and, and,
and there's only one skater left.
It's a skater who usually
finishes below I in competitions.
You could sato again, that's Sandra
Bezac. We all know you could skate it.
She's the kind of scary that puts a smile
on your face. And UCO was, you know,
one of these really lyrical
skaters making his return.
Elvis Stojko and Yuca had it had this
very beautiful style and
grace give her skating
gentle, almost soundless quality
like a whisper across the ice.
Basically heard skating style was the
exact opposite end of the spectrum from
Syria's
Todd, the 21 year old from Tokyo. This is
so she gets up
[inaudible]
what does her final skate
in front of the home crowd?
You guys, one of my favorite skaters,
but she doesn't have the
combination jump like finally did.
So she's going to need all her jumps
opening up in their triple lips and she,
it's
first gen crowd loves
it. Should it go? She,
she had maybe less triples than me,
but she was maybe poor, prettier,
and in her routine there were these
moments where it just looks like she was
just sort of skipping across the ice.
Just very balletic moves.
I know she's good and all
they stand as one here at Mako Hari
Events Center for the local favorite Yuca
Sato.
Now it's down to the judges as to
whether the gold metal belongs to Sato of
Japan or Bono. Leo France.
You could, you know,
get off the ice. She goes to wait for
her marks. First marks, of course,
her technical merit bone Elise
soco stated in jumps so well and every
one of those marks except the finish
judge goat Juke Bona. She wins
eight out of nine technical merit.
But when it came down
to the artistic mark,
it's just the opposite.
Then the technical marks,
eight or nine judges all but the
French judge giving her higher marks.
Those go to you. Casada
this is going to be close.
It actually ends up being a tie.
So it goes to being a
tiebreaker and that's been the,
the judges basically pick first,
second and third. And in a five,
four decision,
she's
[inaudible] world champion for sure.
The trues Hearn ought to the dressing
room or the new champion, she'll be back.
And so will we.
What happens next is one of these moments
that really defines serious story for
a lot of people. So what happened was that
right,
right after all the results were
out, they set up the medal ceremony.
They called out the skaters,
they first called out Yuca she comes
out from this tunnel backstage onto the
ice.
What a moment wades smiles at everybody.
And then after about a minute,
we had one about the silver medalist.
He called out Syria [inaudible]
and where is the European champion? All
the cameras crowding around. And uh,
she didn't come out, not
immediately, a late arrival.
And here she comes,
she skates out onto the ice. She
waves but her face isn't smiling. No.
And then when she gets to the
podium, she congratulates you.
Casado but then finally has
chosen not to stand on the podium.
She just stopped before
getting on the podium.
She just stood right next to the podium.
I think this is a form of protest.
I really hope she doesn't go
to with this. You wouldn't
stand on it. She was crying. Elvis
actually was in the crowd watching.
I felt bad for her cause I know what
she was going through where you know,
you out skated your competitor and
they just wouldn't give it to you.
And I was like Sareah just get
on the podium. Take the metal.
The international skating union
presidents hold off the a ticker skating
official who's giving up the
metals he gives you good.
The gold puts it around her neck,
but then when he turns to, yeah,
he just sort of stands
there. Looks at her.
He says something but you can't hear
what it is. She shakes her head.
He puts the metal around
Sabrina's neck, shakes her hand,
and then he holds onto her hand and just
kind of like, he's her onto the podium.
This is a first
she takes off the metal. Yeah,
sure. She, she takes the
silver metal off of her head
like, oh my God, Holy Shit, he's
actually doing this. It was huge.
It was a huge, it was a huge deal.
The camera zooms in on her face
and she is just weeping. Oh,
what's going on inside that young man?
Yes.
[inaudible] so after the
medal ceremony is over,
she just gets mob
by report. Why did you not accept
the metal? What was the problem?
Because men, my face
[inaudible] they unfair
to use sir. Yeah. What I,
the judges unfair to you today?
Do you feel you were robbed
tonight? Is that what you're saying?
Did you deserve the gold medal? Syria.
And eventually what she says is,
I'm just not lucky.
What, what was going on?
Like what happened? You had a feeling
it was more like a point I'll say,
is this, is it? Stop now. You know,
and you put your, your face on, on a,
on a table. Is it okay? No enough
is enough. That's it. And say, Hey,
you know, I'm not dumb and I'm just
getting sick and now I'm sick of it.
I keep my eyes open is that it's not
fair. We has asked has to stop. I know.
It was just so depressing
and it was so not fair.
Mostly it was not fair
and about, it felt unfair.
Joseph Suno up and over and over
so many times. That's every time.
It's never me because whatever I can
do, how many triple I can be pretty.
It can have as the best choreographer I
can show everything was made to be on a
top and still I'm like, what do you
need more of me to do at this point?
You know how many troubleshoot all you
want me? If I don't, do you kill me?
And if I do, you don't care
in any way. You took somebody,
you choose somebody else.
Don't you think that that's a little
unsportsmanlike? Yeah, totally.
Absolutely. Yeah. But if she,
all these other girls have been worked
just as hard as she has one presumed.
Sure. But okay, so picture yourself.
If you're at that position, you're,
you're in that position. You
find yourself second second.
You feel like you're not, you're not.
She came in second. That's always,
so the margin was so close. It
was so close. I think it is close.
Yeah.
Can I like it? Yeah. Yeah. Google. Um, I,
I just more like felt
empathy for her, for her.
I can't imagine what
it must be like. Well,
I can't imagine what it must be like,
but I, you know, in that kind of,
on that scale to be the
only one and there is this,
um, I think for, you know,
a friend of mine once told me that
racism can make black people crazy,
which is very,
very broad way of looking at it in the
sense that you kind of almost never know
why people are reacting to you
the way that they do. And it's,
and it's kind of, you're
always sort of second guessing,
you know, was that, you
know, did, did, did they, oh,
that guy just came in and he
said hi to everybody in the room.
But he did say to me, what
does that, what was that about?
And so there's no obvious
thing about it, but it,
it can make you feel a little
paranoid, a little crazy.
Now, I cannot put myself, I can't
imagine what, how, you know,
Suria felt in that moment, but I didn't
necessarily like think that, you know,
these prejudice people had denied her
this. If anything, I felt more like,
man,
it Maly must suck to be the only black
woman skating at that kind of level and
not really understand why things are
happening or maybe it must be like a very
confusing situation to
be in. And that is, and,
and it was more like empathy.
I don't know, you know, if, if,
if it, there was racism, quite frankly.
UCO Saddo is an amazing skater. Yeah.
Well I think you're right.
It's very legitimate
to feel like you can't quit
your finger on this feeling,
which
never goes away. No. And never
resolves and is always there
and always makes you feel weird.
Happens. What happens after the A,
that's our producer Matt Kielty after
the ceremony. I think the, I think the,
the,
the rep that she got after this moment
was that she was a sore loser and that
she was defiant, that she had
a bad attitude. And does she,
uh, quit at this point or
no, she keeps going. She,
she competed again in the real
championships in 1995 the very next year.
And she came in second again,
again for three years in a row in
a similar pattern. Was there like,
just the one sort of,
that one wasn't as close,
but she was second again
for the third year.
She's getting a lot of other
competitions after 95 or
I think the various, you know,
European championships, you know,
Skate America. So
yeah, she was doing a lot or she never
wins. Not The Olympics. Not at the world
championships. No. So she
never gets first. Oh, what?
I guess it depends on how you define
first. What do you mean? Oh, you'll see.
So that actually takes us
right back to the beginning.
We're here
live at 10:00 AM on Saturday
morning in Japan. So to be forward,
rewind, we're in Nagano,
Japan, 1998 Winter Olympics.
I knew he was my last
Olympics, last major, major,
big competition and everything was fine
until the day before the short program.
I, uh, I pull a muscle,
her left leg, and I couldn't
lift. I couldn't do anything
to make matters worse.
Ceria at that moment was
already recovering from a
ruptured Achilles tendon.
People had to leave to carry me to walk
stairs because I couldn't get stairs.
So they'd have to lift me to go
to my room because, you know,
at the Olympic village I couldn't
walk. You know, even I'm broken,
I'm damaged. I'm like, used cars as
ready. Good. Good for like for trash. Oh.
Like, you know, Raleigh, I was so messed
up between my legs and my Achilles.
I was like, no, it's the
disaster. And the doctors say,
maybe we should withdraw. I'm like,
no, I'm already here. You know,
I don't want to dress. Maybe retires.
My, probably my last completion.
I don't want to just retire like that.
Just to give them anything you can. Yeah.
I have to keep going. And so on the
final day, she says that she, you know,
between Medici massage, acupuncture
appeals, she goes back out on the ice
that is now getting ready
to skate for her country.
She's in this golden blue sequined
outfit and she starts her routine.
You can tell she's favoring one
leg, but she manages to land.
The two jumps didn't work.
Can you say, okay, then
false.
She gets back up, keeps
going through her routine.
There's the triple sale
code, and then she says,
she just got to this point where
she just knew she couldn't do it.
It was so much in pain and
Josie and I was a program.
I was supposed to go to more triple
and I say, no, what? I'm not good.
I don't feel it. I know I'm gonna
crush. Um, I can do, I'm not capable.
My leg is not with me anymore.
And then what comes to her is that
there is this move that she has in her
repertoire that you can
do, but it's illegal.
[inaudible] a special thing in my
backpack and say, Hey, I can't do it.
It's my last,
it's my last come to show this all going
through your mind as you were skating.
Yeah. Oh yeah, totally. You know me,
it's like a computer who know if I would
have missed something or jump as, okay,
here I can fit a triple here. Obviously
I can do a combo triple, triple.
I know I need to fit something.
You're like the GPS lady.
You're like recalculating. Yeah,
totally rerouting. Okay. Renewed.
Do we have to know right
now? So in her rerouting,
she turns around from skating forwards.
The skating backwards picks up speed
just like she's about to do a triple. But
yeah,
she does eat backflip but
not any old back flip.
She's swings one leg over.
Does the splits in the air
upside down? Yeah. And then
lands on one foot.
[inaudible] stop. When you do
the backflip, do you go, do your skates,
go up towards the ceiling and then
come back down underneath you?
[inaudible] why? Why was it illegal? Well,
it's illegal because
it's so dangerous. Um,
also she says you're supposed to
land all your jumps on one foot,
but she did that here. Oh. Like, oh well
good. You did. I don't want full toll.
Just hold, hold on. Just one. Just hold.
And she couldn't be like totally illegal
because say as long as land on one
foot, maybe we'll be, we will finger about
[inaudible] the program
with your back to the judges
and you know, usually is
it you skate, you perform,
you can smile in front of the camera.
But what it gives you as a mark next
scary for me took like 10 minutes.
Seriously. 10 minutes. People feel
about what should we do? I was like,
oh my God, they didn't know what to
do with me. And I'll say whatever.
Just put a zero and so
we can move on. Yeah.
Here are the marks that you
get mailed. Absolutely. Four,
eight, five two she knew.
How do you get noted and Olympic
competition do a backwards.
So they didn't change their mind
about the back flip in the end. Nope.
So she ends up finishing 10th I'd
like, yeah, I finished in. That's okay.
You go here
now afterwards,
a lot of people interpreted that backflip
as a big fat middle finger to the
entire skating world. I know
you don't want me to, uh,
but I'm going to do this anyway.
But when I asked Ceria if
that's what was happening, she,
no, I don't know why people keep
saying [inaudible]. You know,
I was just trying to be happy.
She said she just wanted something
that was hers. Yes. Yes. Yeah.
Had anyone ever done this back?
Flip onto one blade before? No. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm the one who created this one.
That's why he's calls
a Bonelli. Oh, that's
[inaudible] anyone who did it. Wow. Yeah.
You're the first person in the history
of the human race who has done that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. So
knock on wood, I hope, you know,
I'll be able to die in peace. Don't
steal my backflip is mind my bad. Yeah,
let's, yeah, it's mine.
So I'm just curious,
like what has happened since
this story ended? Well, uh,
she retired from figure skating
after the 98 Olympics. Um,
she continues to do ice
shows like occasionally,
but right now I think the main thing
that she's doing is she's coaching.
She lives in Minnesota and she's
coaching skaters. Yeah. But,
but like when we asked
people like, oh, did she,
did she change the sport? Did
she change figure skating?
The answer they would keep
giving to us was no, no,
she did a lot of you were like, you
know, it's not like all of a sudden,
you know, figure skating
rinks across the country,
across the world are flooded with little
black girls learning their sock howls
in their letters and things like
that. I will say from my, from,
from what I can tell for the
first time that there are,
there's more than one black
skater competing at the
same time internationally at
least, uh, backflips or their back
lips. They no, no back, no back. Sadly.
Are they still illegal? They are
still illegal. Yeah. Yeah. Yes.
So, um,
she was just this sort of like almost
this sort of blip on the skating scene
where she was just, you know,
no one was like her before and there
hasn't really been anyone like her since.
But, but there is this kind
of ironic thing I guess,
which is that if you took her and, and,
and you put her in competition today,
if she was competing on
the world stage today,
she would probably do better
than she did back then.
They've changed the, the, the,
the scoring system. So, so now,
um,
you get points for doing the kinds of
power moves that she was doing way back
when and, and even if you, if you
spill, even if you fail at those moves,
you still get points. You get
points for trying. Yeah. Just for,
for daring and surreal
was uh, was, was daring.
She was a Derrer
pretty sure lots of Nasser
and Tracy Tracy spent the last few months
with us producing that story as part
of the deputy NYC fellows program.
Tracy, we won't miss a lot.
[inaudible]. The piece
was produced by Matt Kielty, original
music from Matt and also from Dylan Keith.
Special thanks to Vanessa Riley,
Moira north skaters, Elisa,
Julie, and Christian Erwin from the Ice
Theater of New York and to Ed Haber for
reporting it all, and a very
heartfelt thanks to Maryland Wiggins.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.